Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are not going to create selfies,
we are going to create NERFies instead.
What are those?
Well, NERFies are selfies from the future.
The goal here is to take a selfie video, and
turn it into a portrait that we can rotate
around in complete freedom.
This technique appeared in November 2020,
a little more than a year ago, and as you
see, it easily outperformed its predecessors.
It shows a lot of strength in these examples
and seems nearly invincible, however, there
is a problem.
What is the problem?
Well, it still did not do all that well on
moving things.
Don’t believe it?
Let’s try it out!
This is the input video.
Aha!
There we go, as soon as there is a little
movement in time, we see that it looks like
a researcher who is about have a powerful
paper deadline experience.
I wonder what the NERFIE technique will do
with this.
Uh-oh.
That’s not optimal.
And now, let’s see if this new method called
HyperNERF is able to salvage the situation.
Oh my!
One moment perfectly frozen in time, and we
can move also around with the camera.
Kind of like the bullet time effect from the
Matrix.
Sensational.
What is also sensational is that of course,
you Seasoned Fellow Scholars immediately ask
- okay, but which moment will get frozen in
time?
The one with the mouth closed, or open?
And, HyperNERF says, well, you tell me.
Yes, we can even choose which moment we should
freeze in time by exploring this thing that
they call the hyperspace.
Hence the name, HyperNERF.
The process looks like this.
So, if this can handle animations, well then,
let’s give it some real tough animations.
This is one of my favorite examples, where
we can even make a video of coffee being made.
Yes, that is indeed the true paper deadline
experience.
And the key to creating these NERFies correctly
is getting this depth map right.
Here, the colors describe how far things are
from the camera.
That is challenging in and of itself, and
now imagine that the camera is moving all
the time too.
And not only that, but the subject of the
scene is also moving all the time too.
This is very challenging, and this technique
does it just right.
The previous NERFIE technique from just a
year ago had a great deal of trouble with
this chocolate melting scene.
Look.
Tons of artifacts and deformations as we move
the camera.
Now, hold on to your papers and let’s see
if the new method can do even this, now that
would be something…and!
Wow.
Outstanding.
I also loved how the authors went the extra
mile with the presentation of their website…look!
All the authors are there, animated with this
very method.
Putting their money where their papers are.
Loving it.
So, with that, there you go.
These are NERFIES, selfies from the future.
And finally, they really work - such amazing
improvements in approximately a year.
The pace of progress in AI research is nothing
short of amazing.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!